at the heart of this argument about
immigration that's sweeping North Kent
that you keep hope with this part of
their rise here is pressure on public
services Hospital places health funding
but also schools especially in schools
funding and schools places
this is hearts down Academy it has seen
a transformation in its demographics in
a very short period of time immigrants
said they come into our country and they
become getting benefits and there you
can't think that like they're stealing
our money
yeah because they think British people
should come first it's our country I
find that it's like that you know
different countries because then you've
got you you get to learn from different
cultures and understand like their roots
and things are really so where your
parents are from Margay some Kent's and
and you're fine with it all you're fine
with having a mate from Poland Bulgaria
no problem
what do you say to a guy in Westminster
in House of Commons who says it is a
problem so no need to back up